i'm very excited here to talk about
how 200 plus business leaders
on how they made their data work harder
than their people and this is really
what it's about it's about um
you're here because you're interested in
data engineering or are a data engineer
yourself
and by that i mean that at some point or
maybe even now like literally physically
right now you're probably building a
report or data pipelines in the service
of business users in the service of
business goals
and sometimes that's exciting and other
times you find yourself wanting to do
more high leverage work and my challenge
is
how can i make your life better in the
next 30 minutes
something that i realized through my
experiences at instabase and trifacta
was that a lot of the mundane parts of
data engineering comes from operational
business workflows
some examples of that are your business
user needs that daily report on how many
customer support tickets are over 24
hours old or they or the sales team
wants you to combine mixpanel and
salesforce data to get a list of product
qualified leads for the day so actually
talking to these business users and
trying to understand their needs is a
key part in making your life easier
in the last year
my team
oh sorry forgot to advance this slide in
the last year my team and i have
interviewed around 200 leaders from
square
stripe airbnb oscar health grab
pinterest doordash about their
operational workflows
and this talk is the result of a lot of
raw boots in the ground conversations so
not really data you'd find by googling
around that much
and we asked these business leaders
three main things how they were using or
wanted to use
data to achieve their goals what
challenges they were facing in doing
that
and how their companies were thinking
about solving those challenges for them
and our results revealed a few key
things so the first thing i'm going to
talk about is the needs
there was a high high correlation
between how successful the company was
and how empowered the business people
felt not just to see their data but also
to take actions on it without waiting
for engineers so we're going to go into
why this is important
but if there's only one thing you take
away from this talk it's if you want to
live a better life as a data engineer
let your business users self-serve
the second part of it was
how did how do data engineers come up
with a system for solving these problems
a lot of these companies had spent
enormous amounts of engineering
resources
on building and maintaining internal
tools that let business people
self-serve i'm going to show you what
an end-to-end user experience for that
looks like
and also a reference architecture for if
you were building something like that
how would you build that yourself
and lastly there was a lot of emphasis
on you might have all of the best
tooling but you're not going to get the
most value out of it unless you know how
to use the right tool at the right time
so we're going to go into a little bit
of when should you use dashboards versus
alerts versus reports versus tickets and
we also picked up a few best practices
that we'll share on how people use these
systems
and finally i'll share some case studies
that are public some that are not and
how these companies have driven results
through that
who am i if you remember one thing from
the slide i live at the intersection of
data and business operations and as
kushir said
i am the founder of logic loop and
disclaimer a lot of these interviews
were our due diligence in the founding
of this company
and what we do with logic loop is help
companies high-growing companies scale
faster by letting business users
actually take actions on the data
but what we realized was all of the
learnings that we had in founding this
company are really not limited to the
product and they're worth sharing with
the general population
and before that i was a founding
engineer at instapase and we were
helping large fortune 50 companies
automate loan and insurance claims
operations and before that built data
transformation software at tri-factor so
if you've used data wrangler or google
data prep
google cloud data prep
you may have run into a bug that i
caused
okay so let's first talk about the
problem we're trying to solve here so
what problem with these business leaders
trying to solve
something we heard immediately was that
companies felt that the analytics and
mlai stacks were almost further along
than their raw basic operational data
stack
and you might ask what operational data
means we'll go that into that in a
second and
the the biggest thing yo is that
sometimes it was easier to actually work
on the harder things because more people
wanted to work on the hard things and
that meant that a lot of the basic
operational workflows didn't get as much
data attention
operations data is everywhere so the
common thread amongst this kind of data
is that it's directly related to the
value that the company is providing
so for fintechs operations means
originating servicing loans facilitating
transactions preventing fraud
for logistics operations means having
the right level of inventory managing
order expectations
for healthcare it's about delivering
timely care in a cost-effective manner
to patients
and since operations is really at the
core
unit of work that a company does
operations data is used to facilitate
this fundamental value creation at a
company
what does that mean so the data has to
come from somewhere and you'd expect
that clean operational data lives in
warehouses that's a great great dream to
have
but the reality is that sometimes not
all data can be in warehouses because
data pipelines take longer to run than
the freshness of the data that you need
enter production databases
now sometimes operations people need to
be able to change values on the fly and
they don't have right access to
databases
enter google sheets
sometimes you're using a bunch of
different sas applications like
mixpanels salesforce whatnot to manage
actions and those become systems of
record so enter all of those sas apps
and then lastly depending on the
industry you're in you might actually
try to supplement your internal data
with external data so you're constantly
relying on external data apis
and coming back to that first part of
the need
business leaders need a system that can
read from any of these data sources so
that they're able to make timely
decisions on their data
what happens after decision particularly
for operational data you have to
translate that decision into actions and
actions can take a variety of forms
again
it could be a slack notification
something like the price of gas went up
today and your delivery margin is going
to go down
it could be an email here are all the
transactions you did this week it could
be a ticket please review jessica
haria's account for fraudulent activity
it could be triggering things in
internal or external systems even
writing feature tables back to databases
and business users need a system that
can allow them to take these kinds of
actions in a controlled manner
so what we just saw was operations data
comes from many places and goes to many
places
and how familiar are you with some kind
of exchange like this where ollie the
ops person needs something to happen
right now
and you danny the data engineers like
actually no i
can we do this next sprint
and for some cases like fraud
this would actually kill companies
because you can't wait for two weeks to
fight fraud that's happening today
the fastest growing companies we found
actually have the most friction around
this kind of operations
and why is that it's because growth
comes with new pressures comes with new
apps being used new people being hired
new workflows new products being added
all the time and all of this creates a
demand for clean operational data which
is a demand for good data pipelines
but only about 20 of the engineering
requests amongst the interviews we did
were actually fulfilled by data
engineers
so the question is what do we do about
the 80
and that is really the core of the
business user's problem it's
simply that 80 of the data needs go
unmet
okay so how do we translate that problem
into a statement that we can actually do
something about
here's a handy formula for how you can
think about this so the amount of work
you have to do increases as your data
increases and as there's more growth
pressure on your company
neither of those are going away it
decreases if you have more engineers
but engineers are really hard to hire we
all know that so the only level you
truly have in making your life easier is
how you can self-serve
systems for business users trying to
accomplish basic tasks
it's also the best way for you to free
yourself up to do high leverage tasks
and progress in your career
and the winning companies of the future
will let their business users do a lot
more than they can do today i didn't
make this law i'm just the messenger
there's a quick uh something for you to
ponder on as you think about yourself
and your company this is a quick
operations data maturity checklist
where your business should be able to
read write and leverage data
what does this mean reading data does
clean operational data exist
does business know where to find it and
can business serve self-serve insights a
lot a lot of bi tools are serving this
need
can the right need is can business users
proactively identify issues debug and
rectify exceptions as they happen in
real time
and the last piece of the need is can
business users automate handling these
exceptions and can they themselves
improve their operational processes over
time
so now that we know why self-serve is
important
let's talk about the what and the how
in this section i'm going to talk about
the business user experience as
told to us by interviewees about what
they'd like to see how they'd like to
interact with systems like that and a
reference architecture of how you can
build a system that facilitates the
self-service
so again just to be clear some of the
motivating use cases here are you might
want to trigger a slack alert when a
large transaction happens you might want
to set a text reminder for users to pay
up you might want to automate weekly
account summary emails
and all of these cases you're triggering
an action
when a certain condition is true on your
data
one of the big debates that people
have when thinking about an ideal
business user experience is
sql versus dsl that's something that we
lived a lot at trifacta and we went the
dsl route
and in an ideal scenario your business
user
is not entirely non-technical
so they're actually semi-technical
business users amongst the companies we
spoke to the best of breed companies
like stripe and airbnb
actually did sql trainings for their
business users for the operations
analysts the risks analysts so they
actually could go in and do more things
with their data themselves
and also we scraped about um a thousand
plus jobs on what operations roles needs
these days and about 39
of them required or desired sql as a
skill so that's definitely something on
the rise and this experience assumes
that you choose the sql route um that's
something that we did because um we
think that sql is the lingua franca of
data
now with these data skills a
semi-technical user can come in and
write a query on top of snowflake one
query on top of google sheets and
another on top of a salesforce api they
can write a fourth query that actually
combines data from all of these places
as if it was on one
database
and they would then configure using all
of this data to configure a slack alert
to configure an asana ticket to
configure the contents of the text
message
and the shift that's happening here is
that the business user is moving from
dependence on engineering to greater
independence they're able to specify
these workflows themselves
and from a pool based mentality let me
keep checking this dashboard every five
hours
to a push-based mentality where
you the data will tell you when
something fails
and consequently you as the data
engineer also need to make a mental
shift
your goal is not to necessarily build
every single one of these pipelines but
it's to build the platform that lets
business users self-serve these
pipelines themselves
of course i have to caveat this with if
it's something that's very mission
critical you still need to be involved
you still need to be writing these data
pipelines but this is for that long tail
that's not worth your time to actually
solve
and what an example if a solution could
look like for this is
this is something that we've been doing
internally i'm sure there's many
alternative just as valid solutions but
one example of how this could work under
the hood
is
ollie the ops person wants to read from
postgres and write to slack or zendesk
or email
and what they do is they send a request
to your webserver you interact with a
user interface they send a request to
that web server and that web server
actually then under the hood there's two
different query workers
one worker is the query worker that just
runs the queries and the second worker
is an action worker that actually takes
the actions on the data and you want
those to be separate because
one it's actually easier to scale them
independently if they remain separate
and two you don't necessarily want your
query worker which has access to all of
your internal data to also be on the
same machine or
be the same worker as the actions worker
which is actually triggering a lot of
things in external systems
so what happens is your request goes to
the web server
the
the query worker picks it up runs the
query against your postgres database
writes out data to your internal
database and posts
a job for the action worker to come and
pick it up read results from the
database and then take actions
simple enough
and now how do we extend that to a
scenario where you want to combine data
from a google sheet
and your internal database
so ali the ops person writes query one
on the database query two references a
google sheet and query 3 combines the
google sheet with the database as if it
were on the same instance so that's how
magical the experience is for them
and under the hood what's happening is
that your query worker is running query
one and query two
and it's writing the results out to the
database but also creating a temporary
in-memory database so we actually use
sqlite for this where you create a
temporary in-memory database that you
then run query 3 on so from the user's
perspective it was always kind of in one
place
but from our perspective we're creating
these things on the fly and on a poor
query level
again this will not scale
where um where the data is large but it
will scale where there's a need for
speed uh so you actually can't afford to
build a whole data pipeline and when the
data is medium size if a lot of
operational workflows that does tend to
be the case and then the query worker
does its usual thing writes back to the
database uh posts a job uh in the job
queue action worker picks it up as
normal but this was one of the
architectures we found that was really
simple and yet super effective in it had
an outsize impact on what business users
could do as a result of something like
that without us having to build it every
single time
so there's a common pattern among the
best internal tools we found at these
companies
it's select data write business rules
trigger actions
and this is a system for business users
to detect and act really really quickly
now say you built this system or you
have this system or you have a partial
solution to it
the journey actually doesn't stop there
because a lot of what you get out of it
depends on how your business uses and
how your organization just uses the
tools that are available to them so
we've picked up some good best practices
along the way on how companies got the
most out of these systems as well
the first thing that's really really
important i realized it might be a
little bit unclear there
is route your data correctly
and
the best companies had a good philosophy
a good set of operating principles for
the right tools to do the right jobs
and so far we've been talking about
taking actions on data but this also
applies to more informational use cases
so i'll drive this point home with an
example
of
say we're tasked with fraud data
operations
so let's think about what is our main
purpose right now are we trying to just
know things about it why are we trying
to do things about it so if you just
want to know something about it
ask yourself do i need this knowledge to
be interactive if i don't put it into a
report so you might an example of a
report could be a daily losses summary
report and that's a great example of
what should actually go into a report
where someone just needs an
understanding of the top numbers that
fit in their brain
if you do need it to be interactive
dashboards are a great way of doing that
and a common case is transaction
monitoring dashboards where business
users are able to come in enter a
customer id or transaction id and get
information they need about that
particular event so that needs more
interaction
now if you're actually trying to do
something about an operational trigger
or a data trigger
ask yourself
do humans need to be involved if they
don't need to be involved stick it into
an automation so you can auto reject
transactions that come from this
particular ip address that you know are
bad
no human should actually be doing that
at your company if you know exactly what
needs to be done
and if humans do need to be involved ask
yourself is it urgent or is it not
urgent and this is where i think a lot
of companies struggle the most
is the urgency is not quite clear
and things go into the wrong buckets
so good heuristic here is if it's a
normal course of action if someone needs
to just review things
create a ticket about it and it could be
in slack you could create your tickets
and manage your tickets in slack but the
expectation is not to treat it like an
alert because if you do then you'll miss
all of the things that are actually
going wrong so here an example of a good
ticket is reviewing large transactions
they're coming in you're reviewing them
and improving rejecting them
and the last piece of it is if it's
urgent such as you know an unusual spike
in losses or whatnot then you need to
have a good system around detecting and
escalating
and a lot of times there's a few
symptoms that come up in companies when
this isn't working quite right
so if you are finding yourself
refreshing dashboards very often
then ask yourself do i just need to know
a single number often
or am i waiting for a data condition
to be triggered such that i can do
something about it so if you just want
to know something stick it into a report
have it send you an email or something
and if you do want if you're looking for
a specific data trigger refreshing
dashboards isn't the right way to go
about it actually set up that trigger
and an analogy is if i'm going to bed
and i want to wake up at 9am
i don't check my phone at 1 am 2 am 3 am
i just set an alarm for 9 am and the
system lets me know when those data
conditions have been met
another case where we've seen a lot of
companies fail is too many alerts
they're getting paged if you're getting
paid more than five times a week
it shouldn't really be an escalation
situation uh it should either go into a
ticket if it's normal course of business
or you should actually be investing more
in reliability not monitoring so that's
something to think about
and then if you're performing the same
actions over and over again
uh try to see if you could automate it
i'm not seeing something that you don't
know already but you would be surprised
how many workflows and companies we
interviewed
triggered a slack alert for a customer
success person to send an email to
someone with a template that is the
exact definition of a thing that can be
automated and should be automated and
that the business users should have the
agency to automate themselves
all right so the next section is just a
deep dive into some alerting and just
general best practices we saw
first in terms of creation
don't realert for the same issue again
this this is a real problem that even
logic loop has
um calibrate as early and as often as
possible and aim to keep the volume on
true escalations low
we'll go into content in just a second
but this content these tips can be
useful either for alerts or for tickets
it can be really valuable to have a good
well-written alert or ticket saves a lot
of time when you're under pressure
and the last piece is think about
how the whole is greater than the sum of
the parts you have all of these things
happening on top of your data
let them not be strangers to each other
so your alerts should work in cohesion
with each other and this isn't one of
the companies that we spoke to actually
they were sending out 20 emails per day
to a certain cohort of customers
without realizing what was going on
because there were so many different
systems that were sending out emails so
try not to miss the forest for the trees
here
and one example of how you can improve
the content of an alert or a ticket here
is by adding a few key pieces of
information
so
what you see here is there's a system of
origin there's a clear owner it's
skimmable
there's a link to more details there's
some relevant info
there is an understanding of how
important how urgent it is in this case
it's pretty bad because it's a 150x of
what you would normally expect um
there's call to action if you can do
that within the alert itself that's
great
and there's a reminder on the sla and
the risk level here
and you can go even further and add
notions of volume this is the fifth
alert that fired this month
and this is an example of one of those
things that might take you two minutes
to go through your slack
channels and notifications or your
alerts and really understand can i
provide a much better experience to
either myself or my teammates and save
them time so if you save someone time
but just adding a link to something and
you're or adding a piece of data in here
that they don't have to click that link
for and if they're seeing that slack
message 10 times a day you're saving
them 2 minutes a year so this is a
really good roi on simple changes that
have outsized impact
and the last thing is that none of these
systems should be static i encourage you
to think about how they're always
improving over time some of these things
honestly these companies that we talked
to have taken yours and yours to
actually perfect these systems
the biggest thing is
improving the signal-to-noise ratio
running regular analyses to
weed out alerts that have more than x
percent false positive relate or
consolidate alerts that have more than x
percent overlap between them and also
one really important thing is to be able
to distinguish between no data and data
that's supposed to be there and isn't
and a lot of times it's not clear where
the issue is or how far down the stack
the actual issue is
a lot of what makes these systems also
work at scale amongst a large group of
users
is if you can treat alerting even
business user logic as code version
control back testing permissioning
approval processes all of those are
things we expect from code and we should
certainly expect that from operational
processes not in code as well
and in terms of the management there's a
whole human side of actually managing
this entire system
you want to make sure that every time
you have notifications or alerts or
escalations you have the common syrup
amount of staffing so someone's actually
taking a look at it it's not going into
the ether
someone can groom backlogs every month
that's been really effective and you
should ideally also be tracking the
amount of time it takes to
resolve certain tickets if you're doing
it manually and understand whether
there's an opportunity for automation
and the last thing is um an opportunity
to also consolidate decision systems
wherever possible this is the kind of
stuff that needs kind of a constant
looking into every six months to a year
and one example of how companies have
typically built up these over time
is again i'm going to continue with the
fraud example
you might start off by just adding a
slack notification every time a large
transaction happens
then as you get more data you would
adjust the thresholds
once you start getting too many slack
notifications then you start putting
them into a review and ticketing system
and then finally once you have enough
confidence about your process then you
can think about auto rejecting so
there's a ladder there of operation
maturity that any new process has to
climb
and the challenge your system will face
is how could it be modular and help the
business user rip and replace parts of
it as they become more operationally
mature
so just as a summary of what we just
talked about is um we can route data
correctly and that we know that it's
important to do that
i shared a little bit of a decision tree
there was a little bit of a deep dive
into alerting best practices or
checklists some examples and then some
stuff around iteration with again
another checklist and an example of a
ladder that you could follow
and the final section of this is um you
don't have to believe me there is a lot
of public documentation on what some of
the largest tech companies we know have
done
so the first case study is oscar health
they're a health care insurance provider
and you you'd ask yourself what is a
healthcare company doing building all of
these systems
but they have a lot of operations needs
and the core business is in furthering
how better you can deliver healthcare
with technology so they built this thing
called automat which is a self-service
configuration platform
and automatic hooks into all of oscar
health's data sets so from providers to
claims to in-app messaging to brokers
and then it allows semi-technical users
from business teams to create their own
triggers they call them recipes
that then generate actions so it creates
an internal task it would send an
external secure message or an email
and automat the way their user interface
was was they use the yaml format where
people eventually picked that up over
time and today automat powers about half
of their internal processes at oscar
uber is another example of a company
that built mastermind you might be
already familiar with it in a different
context
for fraud rules
so ubu was having this
problem around there's a lot of fraud
there's a lot of promotions there's
waste there's abuse there's a lot of
different flavors of it and someone i
spoke to there
actually said that the models were
getting outdated every single week
and they realized that it was not
tenable for an engineer to come in and
code up a response to an active fraud
attack that was happening in their case
they said it took the engineer about an
hour to implement a new change the
system which honestly i think is really
fast most companies we spoke to
took two to three weeks for a new
feature to be implemented into their
risk decision system
and
what they did instead was they actually
had
uh they built a very similar kind of
rules engine that their risk analyst to
come in and within a matter of minutes
implement a change that affects all of
uber's fraud rules
all right cool
and
some of the case studies that aren't
public that are anonymized that came up
in some of our interviews were that
there was this one
very large fintech payments processor
company where they built out a similar
internal tool and it started off with
risk analysts just triggering slack
alerts on data
that's how narrow it started off
and eventually it was used by 40 percent
of all employees
across sales across marketing so risk
start off writing
show me all transactions over 100 000
and send me a slack alert about it sales
came in and said show me all users that
are using 80 of their credit limit and
send them an upsell email and that
ballooned in its use cases and at some
point one of the risk analysts we spoke
to
was saving the company millions of
dollars per quarter with just the fraud
rules that he was writing without having
to touch code
that's a lot of roi right there
another series b fintech we spoke with
uh
realized very quickly that a lot of the
revenues they were in the process of
giving loans out to immigrants
and they realized that a lot of
repeat loan
takers were actually really good
customers if they were able to fulfill
their loan the first time and repay it
then they would actually be able to do
it the second time and they already
trusted the company to do that
and they wrote about eight rules the
head of credit risk and analytics there
wrote about eight rules again without
having to touch the code
that now that retargets existing loan
loan holders that are proving out good
and now that business line is 40 of
their revenue today and that all started
off because he had the ability to
experiment with these kinds of rules and
these retargeting messages himself
there's a recruiting company that got a
32x roi on they wrote one rule to send
out an account summary email so they
their customers or
companies like ours that are trying to
recruit
and they would send out a summary email
to their hiring managers talking about
the pipeline and about the impact that
that company was having and that itself
led to a 32x roi because previously
people
their customer success team was doing it
manually going into the database
writing a query downloading the csv
formatting a table in an html
page within an email and they were able
to automate all of that
and then finally as you see fintech
realized that they had a lot of issues
with the with alerts that were
duplicates of each other so they were
actually able the engineering team was
able to add a single dedupling feature
that saved them two months over the next
12 months of all of the stuff that they
would have to write dedupling logic for
instead
cool so where the end
in summary what we talked about is we
talked about 200 plus leaders um
operations
needs and the need is simple self-serve
and we have a little maturity checklist
that you saw
we also talked about a system for
business alerting and automation in
terms of what it could look like on the
user's side and
an example a very simple example of how
you could power it and we also talked
about how you could get the most out of
these systems or any systems like this
and some examples and case studies of
impact
i find this stuff very exciting i think
about it all day so if you want to chat
let's continue the conversation um if
you want to build it out yourself happy
to chat about that if you don't happy to
do that as well thank you
you